your dreams matter
[Applause]
period millions of books sold billions
of video views six number one audio
books and one of the most viewed tedex
talks in the world she's made a name for
herself by being blunt Unapologetic and
yet totally vulnerable we all know we
need to trust our gut that like that's
du the thing is how I don't know what I
want I can never have it I'm 46 I tried
it's hard it's not going to work out for
me if you are the one that is against
your big dreams in life that is the
reason why you're unhappy we are so
quick to consider what everybody else is
thinking every single day make it a
habit to text a friend if you have
friends that make you wrong for changing
your life for the better that's their
issue it's not yours incredible think of
Mel Robin Mel Robin Mel Robin
need motivation you better watch a top
10 with believe Nation hey it's EV car
Michael and I make these videos because
as a young entrepreneur I struggled to
keep my business going I had no friends
I had no mentors I had no role models
and the thing that saved me was learning
from the success stories of famous
entrepreneurs and in their stories I got
motivation and I also got strategies for
what I could do to grow my business and
not stay stuck and I still need their
stories motivation today so today listen
from one of the best Mel Robbins and my
take on her top 10 rules of success
enjoy it's okay to be
comfortable it's not okay to be
small being too small in life telling
yourself that you should be
small that ah it's okay you know
I that's the number one issue shrinking
yourself you see I for the last couple
years every single January I have taught
a course about the science of dreaming
and not just dreaming but dreaming big
and dreaming big as a way to create a
whole new chapter in your life a way to
tap into your potential and more than
200,000 people around the world have
taken this science of dreaming course
with me and here's the number one thing
that I know noticed after teaching this
course over and over and over again to
people around the world it's that
telling yourself that you're small
putting a lid on your own dreams on your
own potential convincing yourself that
me is okay that's the biggest problem if
you're somebody who doesn't know what
you want I guarantee you it's because
you do things that make you feel small
and then you tell yourself that's okay
and here's the thing that I'm really
worried about I'm worried about the fact
that if you continue to do this if you
continue to tell yourself I don't know
what I want I can never have it I'm 46 I
tried it's hard it's not going to work
out for me if you are the one that is
against your big dreams in
life that is the reason why you're
unhappy that you are the single biggest
loudest voice for why you can't have
what you deserve that is the source of
misery that is the source of feeling
lost and so we got to stop that right
now because the fact is I don't care how
long you've worked on your dreams how
long you've avoided your dreams how long
you've been scared of your dreams how
long you've downplayed your dreams those
dreams are still very much alive inside
of you you're not supposed to be small
you're not supposed to be arguing
against your dreams let other people do
that you're the one who's supposed to
have the biggest and the loudest and the
brightest voice when it comes to the
matter of your dreams rule number two is
trust your gut it's really hard to find
the courage to make a decision that is
the right decision for you and it's hard
because because we are so quick to
consider what everybody else is thinking
we're so quick to weigh how our decision
is going to impact somebody else's
feelings that's why we don't trust our
gut we all know we need to trust our gut
that like that's the the thing is how
and so takeaway number one that I want
you to leave with is stop saying trust
your gut and start saying I need to have
the courage to make decisions that are
right for me second
feeling feeling
feeling give yourself the ability and
the time and the the quiet to drop into
your
body and feel whether or not the
decision or the direction opens up
possibility makes you feel like you're
growing and thriving it levels you up it
may be scary as hell I mean think about
Amy's Story how the hell are you going
to like do 12 months of Revenue in one
month you have you just dis that who the
does that you
do if it feels like a part of you is
opening up there you go there's your
decision if it feels like a part of you
is shrinking oh I'm going here because
everybody in my family went here I'm a
doctor because everybody in my family is
a doctor I live here because everybody
lives here that's not the right
decision and
finally when you do drop in and you
allow yourself to step onto a tour with
the future you you're going to feel the
no first listen to it you're going to
feel the yes cuz it feels like an
opening find the courage rule number
three is Embrace change Alana said in
her opening sentence to me I'm scared of
the rejection I will face when I start
making choices for the new me you know I
read something interesting and I want to
tell you this before I forget it and
then I'm going to talk generally about
friendship hoping that the way that I'm
thinking about friendship will help you
lose the guilt number one um this kind
this came from a book that my husband
was reading about alcohol and it really
what made me stop and think and that is
this when you decide that you don't want
to drink for whatever reason what's
interesting about being somebody that
doesn't drink at a party is that the
only person that gives a what's in your
glass is you nobody else typically cares
but the thing that's interesting is that
when somebody says to you would you like
like a drink and you say no I'm not
drinking I'm not drinking for the month
of January or no I'm sober or n you know
I don't feel like it what happens is the
fact that you're turning down the
alcohol it can actually magnify somebody
else's struggle with their own decisions
around it and so the first thing that I
want to point out is if you have friends
that make you wrong for changing your
life for the better that's their issue
it's not yours and so you got to
untangle the fact that they have baggage
about getting in shape or they have
baggage about going to the bar that's
theirs and it has nothing to do with the
decisions that you're making so if your
friends in general give you blowback for
changing for the better what you need to
say in the back of your mind is
interesting they're obviously very
conflicted about their choice to go to
the bar and drink every night but that
has nothing to do with me here's the
other thing you can do if they start to
make you wrong you can say well you want
to go to Planet Fitness with me instead
it doesn't sound like you want to be at
the bar so that said let me talk to you
a little bit about friends friends are
people that you care about and I have
this test I call it the funeral test if
somebody in your life were to die ask
yourself would I go to their funeral if
the answer's yes they're a friend of
yours that's the test for whether or not
in my opinion someone is a friend
because it means you care about them now
here's the other thing about friendship
that I want you to understand you can
care about somebody and not like hanging
out with them and that's the situation
that you're in right now that you have
plenty of friends that you care about if
they were to die you would go to their
funeral if they needed you you would be
there if you saw them you'd be happy to
see them but you don't like to hang out
with them the other thing that I want
you to think about is that and that's
okay that's like a normal part of
friendship and the reason why that's a
normal part of friendship is because one
of the things that we know about life is
that you're always going to be changing
in the old pattern and the old chapter
you had certain patterns right in the
old chapter of your life you would go to
the the bar and drink you would go to
the store and spend money you didn't
have you're in a new chapter now and so
you have different patterns when your
life takes on different patterns whether
it's you're no longer going to the bar
you're going to the gym the pattern
might even be that one of your kids is
playing with a different soccer team or
maybe you've moved to a different street
in your town when the patterns change so
will your circle of friends it's a fact
of life but that doesn't mean your old
friends the ones that you used to drink
with aren't friends anymore it just
means that you don't want to hang out
with them you still care about them but
you don't like doing what they do rule
number four is be an amazing friend
every single day make it a habit to text
a
friend just out of the
blue and if you want to amplify this
take a selfie video hey I'm just on my
walk and I was thinking of you and hey
my dog says hello and you not only
underestimate how much people like you
you underestimate how much it means to
somebody when they hear from
you this isn't just me this is research
that was covered in the New York Times
recently about how receiving an
unexpected text from a
friend makes you immediately feel
connected to that person and it makes
the Friendship stronger make it a
practice every single day as you start
your day to reach out to one friend with
a random message I want to tell you I
love you I believe in you and I believe
in your ability to stop telling yourself
these lies and to really embrace the
truth the truth is you deserve amazing
friendships you need amazing friendships
and you are that amazing friend that
somebody who is going through a very
lonely season digging their way to a new
life needs desperately right now also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is be confident
in terms of my own experience with
getting serious about creating the skill
of confidence is it's a GameChanger the
more that you build confidence in your
life the greater the risks you're going
to take and that's critical in business
in life for fulfillment I also have the
ability to say no and not even be
bothered by what other people are going
to feel why because I have the skill of
confidence it also makes you an
incredible negotiator because you
realize you would rather be respected
than be liked and see this kind of need
to be liked or to look good is part of
the reason why you doubt yourself all
the time I want you to bring that power
back internally that's what the skill of
confidence does and you'll also be able
to recognize when you're afraid of
something and that that feel fear is
just kind of in your head and
you have a choice you don't have to let
fear stop you anymore and that's where
the skill of confidence comes in and the
same's going to be true for you rle
number six is spend time with the right
people and one of the reasons why it's
so important for you to be clear about
what you want out of this next chapter
in your life is because who you hang out
with it changes everything for you it
either keeps things the same or it will
be an accelerant that makes it easier
for you to make the changes in your life
that you really want to make and so this
is research from Harvard that I want you
to understand and it's what is grounding
the advice that I'm giving you today so
do you know that when researchers from
Harvard looked at people who had made a
major change in their lives in a
positive way okay so you take a group of
people that made a major change in their
life half of those people the reason why
that change happened is because
something either tra atic or something
that was a major life event happened
they got cancer they lost somebody they
loved they got a divorce they suddenly
were laid off they lost all their money
like something happened that was a major
life event that rocked them and you know
what happens when that happens to you
first it's horrendous but it usually
leads to something very positive
happening now the other half of the
people people who had made a very
positive change in their life do you
want to know what they did what they did
is they changed their friends they
started surrounding themselves with
people that were up to the same thing
that they wanted to be doing I'm sure
you've experienced this in your life
have you ever um gone to college and
when you get to college and suddenly
you're around a bunch of studi people it
suddenly makes you more studious have
you ever done a 5k or run a half
marathon or done a big walking uh
fundraiser or done tough mutter one of
those big kind of group events what's it
like to be at a race where people are
cheering you on where other people are
running where you're all doing the same
thing it's super motivating and there's
even deeper research around this because
behavior is
contagious if you're around people that
smoke your objection to smoking gets
lowered because you get socialized to it
if you're around people that are super
positive you your natural set in terms
of being pessimistic will slowly start
to raise if you're around people that
every morning they send a text I've got
two friends hi Jenny hi Sarah two of my
uh friends here that I text almost every
other day about what exercise class
we're going to just being around them
makes me more motivated and so James and
you I want you to really understand that
who you hang out with matters it matters
not only because your time is valuable
and your attention is valuable and your
heart and soul is valuable but it
matters because the people that you hang
out with have an incredible impact on
you rule number seven is learn to let go
I believe that you are capable of
changing I do I've just seen too much
evidence over the course of my career
amazing changes that people just like
you and me have made so I know you're
thinking well this is great Mel but
where do I begin so step number one you
begin by making a wish
just like that moment on your birthday
when you close your eyes and wish for
something to come true in this next year
of your life right now do the same close
your eyes and think about the next year
of your life what do you want the next
year of your life to look like Begin by
making a wish that's how I began two
years ago yep my business was upside
down kids were in shambles my husband
was struggling with depression and I was
struggling with everything I had to
create a break from that moment of pain
and allow myself to see something
different at the time I had no idea what
the new chapter of my life would be or
could be here's what I did know I don't
want to stay in this one and that's all
you need to know all you need to know is
you don't want to stay in the place that
you're in right now that right there is
a wish for something better if you know
what you don't want it's very easy to
change as soon as you start removing or
letting go of things that aren't working
you'll see all new possibilities rle
number eight is just start true
confidence Begins the moment you're
willing to try okay and so I I I really
think it's important I can give you
another example the first time somebody
handed me chopsticks I had no idea how
to use them was I nervous about picking
them up and I couldn't get like my
fingers to twist in the way that you're
supposed to and it was super embarrassed
and they kept like flipping across the
table and everybody here's the thing I
didn't know how to use
them but isn't it common sense that
there's no way I was going to learn how
to use them if I wasn't willing to try
see being confident and the skill of
confidence is the difference between
saying sure hand me the Chopsticks I'd
love to try I'm willing to look like an
idiot I'm willing to be a beginner first
versus going can you get me a fork I
don't know how to use those do you see
the difference the skill begins with
being willing to try so many of you saw
me on the Today's Show today that is the
culmination of 10 years of being willing
to try being willing to walk on a stage
and have a panic attack or a neck rash
being willing to get behind a microphone
and make terrible content or say stupid
things or look terrible in videos you
know you got to remember what you're
seeing is a person on the Today Show who
has been working hard for 10 years
trying over and over and over and over
and learning and failing that's what
you're witnessing you're witnessing
competency but the skill is something
different the skill of confidence is
trying and you know let me remind you of
a fact everybody starts at zero everyone
whether you're trying to learn guitar or
you're building a social media following
or you want to get into the YouTube
space or you're writing a book or you're
selling a everybody starts at zero
that's how I started zero speeches given
zero television experience zero social
media following zero email addresses
zero competency in front of a camera or
on a microphone I mean even take this
podcast starting this I started at zero
the tech is intimidating there are 5
million podcasts on Spotify alone I'm 54
years old I don't know how to do that I
haven't done this before I haven't been
in the seat of the person that hosts but
here's the difference with your friend
Mel Robbins I'm willing to
try I lean on this skill of confidence
that I've built because I have the
definition that's grounded in research
and so do you you're not going to feel
confident you're going to
act in accordance with the research of
confidence you my friend are willing to
try that's the secret number nine is
accept who you are not everybody is
meant to be your friend and the second
that it feels like a force be flexible
okay here's one of the things that I
love to think about is that you can be
the whole package but if you're
delivered to the wrong address not going
to work
another quote that I've seen that I just
love is you could be the most amazing
juicy end of summer ripe Peach but if
you don't like peaches you're not going
to be a fit for that person doesn't
matter how good you are remember
flexibility I want you to understand
this because when you tell yourself oh I
got to be liked by everybody everybody's
got to like me I got to be everybody's
friend that lie turns you into people
pleaser that lie is why you are in your
head going to they like me how do I need
to change I know I'm a peach and they
don't like peaches but maybe if I
disguise myself as a plum they'll
actually like me stop doing that embrace
the fact that you're a peach embrace
your whole package and stop forcing
yourself to be liked by everybody the
reason why this lie is so important to
catch is because there's nothing wrong
with you the more you Embrace who you
are the more you're honest about what
works for you the more you show up as
your full self imagine that imagine
assuming that people just like you that
juicy Peach that you are as you
are imagine if you just assume imagine
if you're flexible imagine who might
show up somebody who likes peaches
wouldn't that be a wonderful change
that's why you got to catch that because
this is about energy this is about you
and where you are in your life and where
you're going matching with beautiful
human beings that are on that same leg
of the journey with you that's what this
is about so be flexible and man you are
a juicy Peach Embrace that stuff and R
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is have more fun one
of the things that I notice can happen
when you are in a period of your life
where you're trying to heal you're
investing in yourself in your personal
growth you mention that you're working
on trauma you're trying to dig out of
some of the holes maybe that you feel
like you fell into you're trying to
change your mindset that's serious work
that was me for years too here's the
problem with having a big healing
Journey you're not having any fun I
think about periods of my life when I
was going through a lot of change and I
was working on myself and I was doing
everything that you're doing every book
I picked up was self-help everything
that I listened to was self-improvement
I couldn't even remember the last time I
read a fiction novel or I went to a
concert or or I went to a party
everything got so serious because my
focus became so serious and my focus was
about improving my life improving my
life improving my life and doing the
work to change your life it's important
doing the work to identify toxic
patterns that you have or bad thinking
patterns that make you feel like that's
super important but you must also double
down on the fun while you're doing the
deeper work and so the first thing that
I want you to do is I want you to set an
intention that your number one goal this
year is to have more fun to invest in
that first category hedonic happiness
that researchers say is so important
because yes it's meaningful yes it's
fulfilling to do the hard work to change
your life for the better but changing
your life for the better also means
that you need more moments of fun in
your
life what is the 5sec rule it's a form
of metacognition that gives you
immediate control over your thoughts and
actions using the rule is so simple the
moment you feel your instincts fire up
just start counting backwards to
yourself to switch the gears in your
mind 5 4 3 2 1 then give yourself a push
forward 5 4 3 2 1 counting backwards
requires focus and when you focus your
prefrontal cortex awakens and by the way
that's the part of the brain that helps
you learn new positive behavior patterns
I first mentioned the rule in its head
talk since then more than 8 million
people have discovered the rule through
that talk and its powerful countdown
trick to take control of their lives
become more confident happy and even
make their dreams come true now first
let's talk a little bit about
productivity as a concept productivity
is not about blasting through your to-do
list and doing more it's actually about
doing less productivity is the ability
to make progress in the things that
matter to you sounds simple right I mean
just move the ball down the field on the
important stuff but it's not easy why
blame your feelings you see you're
capable of being more productive you're
just waiting to feel like doing what you
need to do and guess what you're never
going to crack the whip on yourself when
you have a million other things that you
need to do and you people that are
making demands on you one thing that you
must understand is that you have the
power to decide what's important and
productivity actually boils down to
simple 5-second decisions here's one
that you need to start making
immediately that will have a tremendous
impact on your ability to be productive
when the alarm goes off do you wake up
early to work on your business or do you
blow it off cuz you don't feel like it
you're tired or or do you stick to the
plan to finish some important tasks or
do you Mainline Facebook instead because
ah you'd just rather relax when you
change your decisions you'll change
everything because productivity boils
down to the ability to make small
5-second decisions that put the things
that are important first and here's one
5-second decision that will make you
more productive than any other get up 30
minutes earlier than you normally do and
push yourself to work on the most
important priorities first
this isn't just me research shows that
your most productive hours are the first
2 to 3 hours after you wake up and get
ready this means that for Peak
productivity you've got to do whatever
you can do to make sure the most
important work to you gets done first
during that window of time so here's how
you're going to use the rule the moment
your alarm goes off and you want to hit
the snooze button use the rule 54321
push yourself out of bed then use the
rule again
54321 sit down and get working on the
things that matter to you instead of
checking your phone instead of letting
your day get hijacked you see the moment
you feel yourself wanting to give into
distraction you're going to use the rule
again 54321 do a search control and get
back on task to the things that matter
to you it doesn't really matter how busy
you are we're all busy if you really
care you'll find the time and that's how
you're going to use the rule to find the
time to work on things that matter to
you this is where I think people go off
the rails they they're sitting at home
thinking yeah I want to start a podcast
as well and I want to hear because I
know that you end up doing it on a way
more professional stage but walk people
through what who' you call was it a
relationship that you built 20 years ago
I want people to follow that yeah so
first things first I went to my friend
Google and I'm like how do you start a
podcast honest to God because I I'm
smart enough to know it's different than
radio and I didn't even know what
equipment people have I didn't know
anything about okay do you go to like
how do you put a podcast up do you put
it everywhere I don't know like is there
a form that you put the title on and the
captions and then do you send it
somewhere like I know how to upload a
video to YouTube I know how to but I
don't know anything about this market
and so I went to Google um you're going
to laugh at me but I bought a course
about podcasting not laughing at all um
I uh studied a bunch of videos about the
type of equipment that people bought um
I then just started stalking people that
are doing it and I started to say myself
okay what does somebody that already has
a podcast what do they do that I'm not
currently doing and so the first step is
obviously learn about it identify a
group of people that serve as what I
call your lights on the path and so
lights on the path are people that are
anywhere from one step ahead of you
to 10 years ahead of you and these are
all people that can guide you forward if
you study what they did and most of them
by the way we live in the most magical
period of time you have no
excuse for not walking toward what you
want I realize it may be harder for some
of us with mental health issues I
realize that not everybody starts at the
same uh starting line because of bias
and all kinds of things that can happen
to people but the bottom line is through
your actions and attitude you can create
anything you want and look I'm sitting
here saying I've been wanting to do a
podcast for eight years and for six
years I was nothing but excuses for why
I couldn't get started and then finally
I'm like it I got to start and so you
start by Google the topic number one
become a student of what you want to be
first that's the mindset what can I
learn what are people doing that is
calling to me what are people doing that
I don't like and so as I started being a
student of this really important that's
why I say Google Google is a search
engine become a student of what you want
to learn about or launch in your life
and there's a bazillion books there's
master classes there's free videos
there's workshops and what's so cool
people like Tom are unpacking this for
you with people and so you can also hear
people's stories how can I get started
on my dreams and make them a reality
where do I start Mel there's so much
self-doubt it's overwhelming and I just
don't know where to begin once somebody
knows what they want to change or why
they want to change it the next big
question is how and so I'm going to
answer Jessica's question in two parts
because there are two parts to how the
first part is easy it's the doing part
and how you get started when when it
comes to taking action and you don't
know what to quote do this is easy just
go to
Google I'm I'm dead serious about this
Google has the answer to everything if
you simply go to Google or go to YouTube
and type in the change you want to make
or the goal that you have or the thing
that you want to create in your life you
will probably get 6.3 million search
results and every single one of the
links that you click on will give you a
long list of things that you could
probably do and I'm not being a smartass
here the fact is the steps that you need
to take action-wise are super
simple the reason why you're stuck is
because of the second part of her
question now did you notice she said at
the very
end my self-doubt my self-doubt because
one of the reason reasons why you get
stuck is because of the
doubt and this is where working on your
dreams and your goals gets really tricky
because if your own mindset is working
against you you're actually never going
to feel inspired or motivated or
encouraged to take the actions that that
Google result just told you to take and
so we got to focus on your mindset first
and foremost when it comes to where do I
start because I want to play this out
with you let's just roleplay here if
you're sitting there going I would love
to become an opera singer but I don't
know but self-doubt but what if I sound
stupid but this but that but what if
Uncle Willie if you start doubting your
ability to make that happen how
motivated do you feel if you're sitting
there telling yourself that you can't do
it or that it's not going to
work this is the reason why
most people never even get started on
their goals and dreams their thinking
pattern is the problem because their
self-doubt their perfectionism their
lack of self-worth it's convincing you
not to take the action passion is
something you feel I think about passion
as another word for energy passion is
something you feel passion is so simple
to bring into your life because passion
is literally just about getting
intentional about filling your time with
things that bring you energy it kind of
makes sense right that's all the passion
is and now that you understand this
simple idea of what passion is that
something you feel it's for you it
brings energy into your life you now
understand why people say oh I'm living
my passion I would never use that
sentence because I think the accurate
thing is I feel passionate about my work
as a doctor what they're saying when
somebody says that is is they're saying
I feel energized by my work and if you
are one of the 89% of people that feel
stuck right now here's what I know if
you look at your dayto day in your week
to we life you are not doing anything
that naturally brings energy into your
life positive energy and a simple way to
flip the switch and bring more passion
into your life is to become intentional
about making time to do the things for
25 years uh I've had a headful of ideas
I've had half ass projects and lots of
plans uh I chose always wishing
overdoing U many of U my blocks were due
to fear many just basic survival uh the
idea of goal setting it really fires me
up uh the idea of remembering to revisit
those goals that freaks me out I just
think of all the things that I should
have done and want to do still um that I
again I've thought about over the last
25 years what do you have a vision board
for that seems
like what are you a child let me tell
you why vision boards can be important
with one huge caveat based on science
vision boards are
important because when you take the time
to create a vision board which is
basically bringing your dream or your
goal to Life by creating a collage of
images what you're doing is you are
grabbing that dream or that goal that
typically we bounce around in the back
of our minds in private you're pulling
it out of your mind
and you are grounding it in reality and
one of the reasons why this can be so
powerful is because it signals to your
brain that this is really important to
you we've talked in previous episodes
about the zynic effect it creates this
kind of to-do list in your mind the
other reason why it's important is
because when you put a vision board in a
place where you can see it it keeps
these goals and dreams front and center
which is really important but here's the
problem
everybody puts the wrong on their vision
boards you've been sold a bill of goods
you have been told that if you simply
create a collage of some beach house or
your dream body or a million dollars in
the bank or a Maserati that suddenly the
universe is going to hand you those
things that's not how that works what
research shows is exactly what relle is
talking about if all you ever do is
think about the big thing you think
about the end goal the beach house the
Maserati the thing that's like 10 years
from now and then you create this
beautiful collage of this amazing thing
that you want that's a huge mistake and
see everybody makes this mistake if you
look at anybody's vision board you know
what's on it it's beach houses and a
million dollars and a Maserati and the
the finishing line at the New York City
marathon and all the things that you
hope and dream for and the reason why
that's a huge mistake is that if the
only thing that is on your vision board
board is the thing that's going to take
you 10 years to get done as you sit here
in your studio apartment or in the spare
bedroom of your parents house at a desk
in the corner and you stare at a $10
million beach house oh my God that is
going to feel so far away it's going to
feel like you might as well move to Mars
for crying out loud instead of that
vision board keeping your dreams from
and Center that vision board is rubbing
them in your face it's not motivating at
all why because you start to become
present day in and day out to how far
away you are from that dream of yours
and that starts to make you feel less
motivated it doesn't surprise me at all
that relle has been thinking about all
kinds of things for 25 years and yet she
can't get started and the reason why is
because she is making the mistake of
visualizing the end the question is how
do you deal with the anxiety that comes
from waking up and being on a roll and
realizing that when you're making things
happen it's easy to look back and
realize how much of your life you wasted
and that makes you present to how
potentially little time you have left
and how much there is to do in the
little time that you have I can so
relate to this so relate to this the the
few things I want to say about this is
that I don't think that our experience
of feeling anxiety about getting it all
done before your life is over getting it
all done in the time that you have I
don't think it's Unique I think that
that is something that starts to happen
when you feel like your life is on a
roll and you're not present to misery
but you're actually present to power
and joy and all the cool possible things
that you could do does the anxiety or
how do you make the anxiety go away I
don't think you can I think that that is
a very normal thing to feel when you're
a big thinker and you become present to
the fact that when you put in the work
and when you focus you really are
capable of creating just about whatever
you want in your life and that's both
empowering and daunting and terrifying
as hell and so you can't get away from
that anxiety but you can respond to the
trigger I often feel what you're talking
about when I'm on an airplane and maybe
it's because I'm really V I feel very
vulnerable and out of control when I get
on a plane and I click the Buckle and I
realize this puppy could go down and
then I think about okay I spent 49 years
here there's so much more I wanted to do
so I can relate to this so there's two
things to this one is being present to
time passing and the fact that we're all
going to die and that your life is a f
gift when you get present to that that's
the biggest motivator on the planet and
when you feel one of those moments what
I do is I shrink it down and I try to
find something in this moment that I'm
incredibly grateful for so that if it
were to end right now then all would be
well I think about the sunset I'm
looking at I find a picture of my kids
and my husband I think about you know
the lives that have been touched by the
5sec rule and that gratitude in the
moment allows my mind to not go psycho
thinking about the big vastness around
life and those big topics so that calms
me down immediately that's number one
number two I think a slightly different
question than um I it's probably anxiety
but I think it has more to do with
momentum and how when you start to get
unstuck and you start to see things
happening you'll know notice that things
feel like they start moving faster as if
you are on a treadmill and somebody has
secretly come up and turned it up on you
and there are days where we're moving
through our day like this morning was
one of them we're getting ready for this
live training and all of a sudden I
caught myself almost about ready to
hyperventilate because I wasn't present
to this I was present to what happens
when we have a thousand people show up
and where are we going to
hold you know you kind of speed it up on
yourself so when that happens I know
that I'm in the future
54321 I need to be right here and right
now and that when you start having big
things happen and when you start feeling
unstuck and when things start moving the
momentum you know because an object in
motion tends to stay in motion your
anxiety will make it roll faster that
will not make you effective you have to
slow it down immediately just in the
case of getting overwhelmed by the big
themes in life life when you start to
feel like things are going too fast oh
my God oh my God I don't have enough
time I don't have enough time no yes you
do slow it down okay you know I'm always
looking for new ways to explain the
power of the 5-second rule and the power
of 5-second decisions and I read
something that Tim Ferris said that
really resonated with me and he had this
one line buried in a podcast somewhere
that just jumped out and it's it's it's
stuck and what he said is he said
something about how there's a gap
between the world and the things that
trigger you and your response and your
entire life is that Gap when you start
to this is not what he said he kind of
identified this Gap and I of course
intrinsically was like well absolutely
that's the 5-second window between
instinct or stimulus and your reaction
and when you start to understand that
your whole life plays out in this five 5
Second Gap and that there's a gap that's
5 Seconds long between fear and courage
and there's a gap that's 5 Seconds long
between self-doubt and confidence that
is your life and what's super cool about
understanding that your whole life is
inside this Gap is it's so small
everybody that you have the ability to
control it life's always going to throw
triggers at you and there will always be
all kinds of cool things that inspire
you your wisdom and you get to choose
what happens in that Gap do you succumb
to an excuse or do you push yourself
forward when you start to speak up in
business you'll be shocked at how you
start to speak up in your relationships
when you start to make hard phone calls
whether it's in a selling situation
you'll be surprised at how you'll start
to close the gap and have hard
conversations in your personal life and
so that Gap is everywhere and it's the
same everywhere and when you start to go
to work in controlling how you live in
that Gap between stimulus or idea and
your response that's where the magic is
and that's what you're experiencing if
you feel stuck right now if you feel
like you're in a rut if you just got
dumped or fired or you're going through
a divorce or you put on more weight than
you've ever had or you're just feeling
kind of lost in life you have no clue
what you want to do here's a tip from
your friend Mel Robbins if you don't
know what to do in that situation sign
up for something
challenging train for a marathon commit
to doing something that feels hard as
hell and that pushes you outside of your
comfort zone something that forces you
to add something new to your life like a
training run every single day or a class
where you're going to learn something or
a meditation challenge or Hell 75 harder
how about this one if you don't know how
to swim and you're an
adult it'd be pretty confronting to go
to your local Y and sign up for an adult
beginner swim class and learn how to
swim
which is a life-saving skill or maybe
you want to sign up for tangle lessons
and you've always thought about how fun
it would be to dance and competitions
see what's interesting about a challenge
of something scary and hard is it forces
you to level up every area of your life
because you won't be successful adding
this challenge into your life and
completing the goal if you don't change
your life and your habits and the
systems of your day-to-day life in order
to be a person who can achieve this goal
it literally shocks you to your core
when you sign up for a challenge and it
reminds you I'm more powerful than I
think I'm not stuck in this situation or
this relationship or this dead-end job
I'm more powerful than I think and just
trying this online challenge or training
for this Marathon or this you know road
race or this walking thing or whatever
it's getting me back in touch with me
it's a message everybody needs to hear
because there's only one thing I want
you to do this
week
nothing do
nothing wait a minute Mel
Robins are you smoking something over
there did you just say do
nothing and here's the funny part about
this I bet you might be doing something
right now cuz you're a multitasker and
so am I you're listening to me while
you're doing the dishes while you're
walking the dogs heck you and I might be
at the point in our relationship where
you are actually sitting on the toilet
and I'm in the bathroom stall with you
as you're listening to this don't tell
me that you have not taken me into the
bathroom because I can even feel it over
here and I say this because we got to
talk about the Art of Doing Nothing and
look I'm not stupid enough to think that
you can actually do nothing I mean
obviously not this is like a
metaphorical conversation because you
probably have to work I personally love
working between the week of Christmas
and New Year because nobody's there so
you can kind of like work half a day and
you get the full-time pay and it's way
more stress free and you can get more
done because you aren't in a million
meetings but if you do have the time
off let me guess what are you doing with
the time off you're rearranging your
cupboards you're probably trying to
learn Spanish you're doing a million
things on your to-do list you are like
just keeping
busy this week just
stop please I want to explain this
concept this metaphor of doing
nothing being able to do nothing whether
it's just for a minute or it's for a day
or it's for a week this is so important
and I'm having the conversation not only
with you I am talking to myself right
now too I have a hard time doing nothing
why well because I'm just like you I'm
addicted to being busy I'm addicted to
my to-do list writing them out Crossing
them off throwing them away losing them
writing another one especially in the
world
today the world has glamorized being
productive being busy go go go hustles
hustle culture having a side hustle I
mean there's so much to hustle around
some days I literally have no idea what
I'm doing you may always be on the go
like I am but are you actually getting
anywhere because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for 10 more amazing rules from Marie
forio check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you then
Neuroscience has taught us incredible
things like that our brains are
continuously shaped by our thoughts and
our experiences and you know this to be
true negativity is one of the most toxic
forces on the planet it's toxic for your
brain